oh look at this
look at this welcome to fat man beyond
i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard
hey hello um apologies in advance i'm on
our 70 almost 73
of a fast that's probably going to go at
least 96 hours
and right before we did the show tonight
i went and hiked running canyon
uh at night and i am
i'm [ __ ] tuckered man really tuckered
really spent i was like oh when i'm done
with running it's gonna be so nice to go
to sleep and then i remembered
no no i gotta do it talk about nerd [ __ ]
but that woke me up excellent that was
enough to give me a fuel injection of
like adrenaline like oh we're going to
talk about
dune and here i am never miss an
opportunity to talk dune with
mr mark bernard
it was [ __ ] dope that trail we'll
talk about in a minute but before we do
anything else kids
the we got a sponsor this week uh once
again
the good folks at manscaped are back
they care about the lack of hair on your
balls right not at all support for fat
man beyond is brought to you by manscape
who is the best in men's below the waist
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
they obsess over their technology
developments to provide you
the best tools for your grooming
experience man
um i actually have a manscaped story do
you
i do please do tell i didn't use it
myself
okay my ball hair is not out of control
never has been never will be excellent
you're you're well-liked
they look like pioneers all the hairs
look like pioneers of my balls like it
looks like
far and away the tom cruise nicole
kidman movie where they just start
building in the middle of the irish
sooner or later it's going to end with
like a [ __ ] crane shot up from my
balls and then my balls come back to
life and it swoops back down
yeah she should have killed those balls
man it would have been a better movie if
it happened
close on your balls um here's what
happened
do tell uh harley as a boyfriend my
daughter harley has a boyfriend named
austin he was the star of our
sun and lockdown shorts we were doing
for the tbs show celebrity
um the other day he was passing my
office and i'm cleaning up my office and
stuff going through it
and you know i've got a box of the razor
and a bunch of
fine products to put on your nuts and i
said uh jam
just joking around i was like hey austin
you want this manscaped
kit like it's for trimming ball hair and
he goes oh my god yes
and it was i felt so dirty like in a
weird way because i'm like oh it's not
that weird
man yeah i guess not because i'm like
wait a second when he trims that ball
here
who's gonna know
[Laughter]
but the youth the point of the story the
youth because he's 25.
way into the ball hair maintenance you
know it's it's
it's more than i wanted to know about
austin i met the kid twice
lovely guy sure
okay clean as a baby go for it pal i
guess man he likes it telly savala
smooth and kids if you don't know who's
telling you
he's just he's vin diesel from the 70s
there you go
fond of lollipops totally just like vin
diesel so
here we got ourselves some uh manscape
ladies and gentlemen
uh you know what you do you get 20
off plus free shipping if you use the
code fat man
all one word at manscaped.com and your
balls
will thank you man are you kidding me
the kit is gorgeous
and you could probably use that razor on
your face too i've used the razor on my
face i've used the clippers on the head
so you've used the clippers i have to
and the clippers aren't just like for
ball hair
it's not like shaped like a ball sack or
something no they're
not they don't have they're not cupped
like this that's
hard to shave your head pretty much but
it's uh no it's it's perfect
that's how i've been keeping my head
nice and tight during quarantine since i
can't go to the barbershop but i can't
be [ __ ]
a 1970s junkyard dealer so i got to get
myself right
manscape [ __ ] wait who are you in
that equation are you sanford or lamont
i guess they're both fred or lama
i'm uh i'm lamont that's fred
i i don't i yeah i fancy myself a
younger man
than fred um you ca there i could think
of no better vouching
for manscape than mark bernardin who's
like it's so smooth i'll use a ball
shaver on my head
yes his head is [ __ ] testicle smooth
right now treat your head like you treat
your balls
or vice versa that's a pitch line they
ought to buy that lineup
what a writer right there lazy get 20
off and free shipping free with the code
fat man
at manscaped.com m-a-n-s-c-a-p-e-d
ped.com that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscapescape.com and use the code
fat man what do you what do you got a
jungle down there
shave your nuts [ __ ]
[Music]
yours is way better than mine do you
want to be grizzly adams or do you want
to be shaggy
like oh [ __ ] how deep do you want that
beard to go or just like little draft
dodger beard oh i thought you meant
shaggy like wasn't me
you meant shaggy old school
there's a guy zoinks is the expression
of trimming your balls
yeah and you don't want to see the toys
when you're trimming your balls you want
it to be
nice and smooth you'll never say zoinks
with manscaped no
you won't there's a third tag we're just
throwing tag
tag lines out at them left and right i
feel like we're in an ad agency man you
and me are we're the modern day don
draper
one of us might be
um all right thank you to the good folks
at manscaped
go to manscaped.com right now use the
code fat man
20 off you heard us free delivery um
you know speaking of clean balls
yes mark do you mean this could possibly
you mean our
advertiser could possibly have relevancy
to the first thing we're going to talk
about
you know is this the first news story it
is now
i uh i've been working on segways for a
long time it's [ __ ] smooth
you know i mean we've been we've been
even smoother when somebody calls it out
and gives you applause for it and it's
like
did you just do this nice segue and so
rarely can you actually dip straight
from
are you keeping your balls trimmed to a
news item but
this week this day where we're all
talking
or at least familiar with or at least
seen the trending item on twitter
yes um you know who might also use
manscape products
keeps it nice captain america that's
right man there he is the cap himself
not the pick in question obviously no
because apparently what has happened
is that uh mr evans chris yes um one of
the chris's one of the hollywood chris's
of which there are
one of the finest chris's that this
business has ever offered anybody
for some the best of the chris's um
seems to
have accidentally a dick uh
pick oh um he does have it maybe better
i mean it's america's dick
and it was on full display really uh on
uh
apparently a an image from his camera
roll ended up on his instagram account
how um it seems as if it was by himself
he did it
so he took a snap of his photo gallery
yes he did a little screen grab
of whatever was in his photo gallery and
he didn't think to look at all the
photos first
um no no there there was a few people
who were very excited about um chris
evans having a
picture of an own his own meme saying
guard that [ __ ] and
lots of people were perfectly happy to
volunteer for that level of security
what does that mean exactly guard that
[ __ ] um in reference to him is he the
guardian of that [ __ ] i believe he is
the guardian
or is he like uncle sam like guard that
[ __ ] you know
maybe it's both maybe he's just very
very concerned
about it you know what whether or not
you agree with
the language excellent sentiment indeed
indeed all [ __ ] should be guarded it
should you know
and it's not our job to guard it but if
you need help
apparently there can be uh services
rendered
not to be confused with the other chris
evans meme uh
savage all dicks
yeah and uh and so so yeah apparently
he tweeted out how does this [ __ ]
happen by
accident you know i don't know all the
pictures on my camera roll
by accident i know but before you post
any i checked the background of
every photo i put up on instagram just
in case there's some [ __ ] like
slenderman in the background or some
[ __ ] that i don't see
i i it's weird that my man didn't think
to be like
say what else is he is that my dick and
do we even know if it's his his dick um
it could be somebody else's
it has not been confirmed by the person
in in in
command of said guarding [ __ ] has he
said anything
uh he he there has been no statement no
whoops
from mr evans and or steve rogers here
comes the most perfectly timed
uh uh bom mo within the next i don't
know 10 hours i'm sure he'll finally put
something up
yeah um but he had since pulled it down
because that's also not a thing that you
just leave up there in perpetuity
i mean i guess you can't like but
pulling it down calls attention to it
but at the same time leaving it up
everyone's like
getting their jeweler's loop out and
looking at a tiny ass picture of a dick
so is that why all those what does it
guard the [ __ ] yes
they're all very um pixelated
because it's a tiny pivot that they had
to blow up
indeed um i feel as if you know these
these straight pixels have been examined
about as much as the
zapruder film by now no doubt about that
blow it up to the left
back and to the left zooming in that
dick hangs back and to the left
low into the left because apparently
he's very well endowed
oh [ __ ] wait why'd you bury that lead
that's what you start with you go from
manscape to do you know how big chris
evans dick is and i'm like you have my
attention sir
i was not heading i hadn't even thought
about that how is it i haven't seen it
i'm literally going on reports from the
internet
which like literally there was some fast
denial from mark
right there but uh yeah there was some
picture of like captain america carrying
mullinger
still yeah it's america's dick he's got
a hammer
he's got thor's hammer but yeah there
was some like picture of the the
the trough that a whale dug in the sand
on its way back to the ocean
and people were putting that upside down
like oh chris evans dropped something
i mean look like at the end of the day i
know it wasn't a part of the plot they
didn't feature it in the movie
but i feel oddly comforted knowing that
captain america is a giant dick
captain america's packing america [ __ ]
yeah
but why wouldn't he they took a skinny
dude they came super soldier serum
what it wouldn't work on his dick of
course it [ __ ] hit his dick dexter
they probably put it into the dick dick
first i mean we never saw that but there
were a lot of needles
that's true once he got in that thing
[ __ ] the iron maiden all those
needles that's true a couple of those
needles were probably like
yeah that doctor what's his name the
doctor who dr erskine
yeah doctors kevin's probably is it her
skin er yeah
who's the doctor that finds martian
manhunter
uh that i don't know somebody look that
up would you
um erskin he's the the german dude right
stanley tucci
i was going to say dr tucci yes dr tucci
he seemed like a compassionate dude who
would want to be like we should we must
make sure that he is big
everywhere yes we don't need a mig man
to become big
we can make him bigger which since
like you could can captain america be
stabbed
yeah but what he just heals well yeah
like he gets a [ __ ] kicked out of him by
bucky
in a in um that's true yeah and thanos
as well
yeah he's not impervious to pain but
he'd be impervious pain for me and you
oh well yeah i mean hey we couldn't it
would be that thing where he puts his
hand in her forehead
would you be swinging wildly and never
making contact what about what about
uh dick strength you think if you kick
him in the nuts he's like
stop it or is that where he's vulnerable
is that is that his achilles heel that's
his kryptonite
um wow never thought we'd be sitting
here you know what i did i figured
sooner or later we'd be talking about
chris evans dick because it's just so
[ __ ] luscious everyone knew without
even [ __ ] saying it
i mean once you grew the beard you know
and it was like thick and manly and just
filled with flavor like you just knew
once he put on that cable knit sweater
you knew what was underneath
man oh knives out not the owners
excellent ransom indeed um
yes knives out all day long and [ __ ]
um bottoms up i mean i i would say like
oh he must be embarrassed but like
you know as long as everyone's going
like hey i saw it he has no reason to be
embarrassed right this could have gone a
very different way
yeah you know it's like ah so i guess
congratulations chris evans
i mean of all of the ways this could
have gone i saw that the internet rushed
to his aid by posting pictures
just normal pictures of him to dilute
the stream
so people looking for the dick pics
wouldn't find them or dick pic rather
it seems as if you know the the world
wanted to shelter
this particular so weird uh you'd
imagine he'd want to
i don't know shield that dick um
some things you can't put a shield in
front of some things you can't protect
so some things you don't have to um so
damn true what is it guard the [ __ ]
yeah it is guard the [ __ ] or guard that
[ __ ]
i think it's that [ __ ] but i could be
wrong
like a chant like build that wall guard
that [ __ ]
lock her up of all of the
pussy-related slogans we've had in the
last four years
i prefer this one i dig it as well guard
the guard that [ __ ] kids
there yeah moving off unless you don't
want to in which case
it's yours to do with as you will yeah
yeah don't
be carefree with that that sounds worse
yeah just guard that [ __ ]
uh use that [ __ ] with initiative um and
also care
yeah i
you better leave this story behind and
jump into the real news
although hell of her story i mean
holy [ __ ] like [ __ ] impressive
saturday
is usually like fridays that take out
the trash day where they just dump the
news they hope just goes away and nobody
notices
saturday nothing ever [ __ ] happens on
saturdays suddenly
zip indeed
chris evans [ __ ] has entered the
conversation
while i whip this out god so
[ __ ] like blessed hell of an actor
giant dick seems like a nice guy too
yeah yeah yeah from what i can tell
um and might not even need to be with a
dick like that
yeah well why you think people with big
dicks get to be mean
he asked not having a big dick
confessing
fully that his dick's not big because i
i think i
i i got nothing to lose right i believe
they think they have an advantage
i'd like to go the other way where
people with big dicks are like you know
[ __ ] hey
and all that's cracked up to be you know
it's it's tough to find someone who'll
take a big dick and [ __ ] like that
that's always
trying to paint a [ __ ] cloud on it
this sounds like the worst penthouse
letter
which like oh man dear abby i don't know
what to tell you
but the giant dick is giving me problems
i'm happy for him i'm glad he's got big
dick good for him big bank account big
dick
all these women just want to sleep with
me because i've got this giant dick
and it's making for very shallow
relationships
nothing shallow about a big dick man
[Laughter]
uh what else we got who else showed
their dick today mark
did [ __ ] iron man show his dick did
uh loki
there was another giant worm on display
yes yes yes there was
that segway just [ __ ] came to me my
god you're the segway king tonight
you're on fire knocking them out the box
rick i got to stop hiking running right
before the show i lost all my good
segues up on brendan kenny
that's a hell of a segue um are you
talking about a sand worm
i am talking about the shy hallowed baby
it's big news for us kids listen
i don't know how the internet reacted to
this trailer i think i saw some piece
where they were like
you know [ __ ] dune fans were in like
flynn
and [ __ ] you know people who never
heard of doom before were like
is that pink floyd is that zendaya and
stuff
so it didn't i don't know if it took the
whole world by [ __ ] storm
but it definitely took me by storm and
what i was shocked by but then
not shocked because i talked to my
friend vincent pereira and he's a big
david lynch fan
and i was like oh my god the [ __ ]
trailer is like
beat for beat lynch is [ __ ] dune and
he was like that's because
you know for i know a lot of people [ __ ]
on lynch is dune
not in this house not in this [ __ ]
house but vinnie said that like
um frank herbert loved
[ __ ] so like
yeah that's the guy that wrote the book
um so
it makes sense then that like as i watch
this trailer i was like oh my god like i
know every one of these scenes
oddly enough i thought i'd be seeing
[ __ ] i hadn't seen
in david lynch's dude like maybe some
like look at this
now we're doing this so here's a
storyline i never but
it's pretty [ __ ] beat for beat yeah i
mean it it i mean we should probably
just like take a look at the trailer and
then we can talk about it on the back
side
are we allowed to you know what i feel
like last time we ran the trailer they
[ __ ] threw us off youtube
warner brothers both of the warner
brothers called up youtube i know
good cop and bad cop jack warner and
frank warner and and and and jackie
warner kersey
and kersey kurt warner
um yeah so should we do it i think we
should [ __ ] do it i think we need to
steer into the skin
do we do we turn it do we just leave the
volume off
do we dim it a little bit yeah jc i have
it turned
way down so you kind of hear so it's
more
us on top yeah but it'll be mostly you
guys all right we're gonna try this kids
but no guarantees youtube don't throw us
off if you're watching on facebook
you're [ __ ] fine facebook
you know what they allow everything god
like [ __ ] misinformation they don't
give a [ __ ] it's a wild wild west
but youtube still has some standards so
they might chuck us off
for watching this which if that happens
we'll be right back
yeah and if it doesn't happen good
because youtube is coming to their
senses
yeah what the [ __ ] guys have you seen
the internet like it's nothing but
repurposed
content yeah we're trying to sell your
[ __ ] warner brothers
yeah you put out a product definitely
sell it too this ain't even like
a paid gig we're like oh [ __ ] we're not
gonna slap our sandworms all over it and
call it
nancy we like it the sleeper has awoken
warner brothers
um all right let's take a peek all right
oh sweet warner brothers yeah even that
logo
legendary it looks so legendary
um he's i mean look i liked him a lot
and call me by my name
um but i think he's a really good paula
tradies man
and i think he's he's young which is
good
yeah because kyle mclaughlin was like a
40 year old man
right he's like well i'm still a baby
prince and look at all this gray hair i
have
um this is the benny jesuit witch
um with the [ __ ] the box what's the
box called
uh it's the [ __ ] gum jabar
you have to do that right yeah well done
excellent pull
ah what's in the box i saw your [ __ ]
your instagram what's in the box
um even the suit the protective gear
suits
are not that far removed no from the
dune version
some like shimmering cg yeah which in
the 84 version was just these weird
blocky [ __ ] things because
1984 was not big on cg
duke leto tradies looks so [ __ ]
awesome you know anything about this
story don't don't get too attached to
oscar isaacs
no is that javier bardem he's playing
the max von sedal rules
right kinds i think and then um
rabon is uh dave batista
and there's two quick shots of uh stalin
skarsgard
yeah and jason momoa is duncan idaho a
lot of shots of him
they're like hey kids remember aquaman
he's in this movie
we got all that drogo up in here um
one person they don't show is
uh it's one character we haven't seen
yet
one actor very famous who's in the cast
and i didn't see him in the trailer
well you know who else we haven't seen
what our boy does mulching
that's right because he plays um what's
his name the guy that he plays the men
he plays uh not through for howard but
he doesn't play foofa
he doesn't play football oh you play
football
um yeah this just looks [ __ ] epic
oh man and and perfect and it was great
that they [ __ ] used
uh pink floyd man because
remember judorovsky's dune that's what
he wanted to score it with was pink
floyd
yeah and uh i will say that this trailer
as much as i do like it
follows the exact pattern of that how to
make a blockbuster trailer
absolutely we put up like here's the
giant thing
that's a big [ __ ] sand worm this one
shot right here where the wall of worm
goes up him looks like the other dune
that shot's [ __ ] badass yeah so what
do you think the worms doing is he
waiting or is that one [ __ ] paul
because paul jumps on its back and
right i don't think that's that yet
that's not that that's when he and
and his mother lady jessica are
essentially
they're just seeing the [ __ ] woman
right like they're they're they take
it's when they get captured by baron
harkonnen and they escape and they're on
a [ __ ]
sand skimmer thing that gets shot down
and they land in the middle of the sand
and they have to plant a couple of
thumpers to draw the arms away
so they can get to the safety of rock
and then they turn and then they see the
giant [ __ ] worm
and that's when they meet the fremen
sorry don't want to spoil
a a 30 year old movie and be a 50 year
old book in a book that's very
out there as well and a mini series
where you always figure out a mini
series
you know it looks [ __ ] dope
i know what i'm doing when it comes out
going to see it
yeah uh i mean and i did it like an
informal survey on the internet um when
it dropped where i was like hey listen
this trailer is awesome for me yeah but
i am all about dune i'm all about the
lynch i'm all about the book like i
i i've lived and breathed this for a
good long time so i know what i'm
looking at
if you have no context for this how does
it strike you
random person on the internet and i want
to say it was like 80
of them were like i don't get it like it
looks kind of why a it looks kind of
just dusty
why a yeah so dismissive indeed
um and looks like stuff that i've seen
before
um which to be fair everybody stole from
it
it is a bit like john carter of mars in
that way where star wars was very much
influenced like there's a reason why
tatooine is a desert planet because he
really liked arrakis there's a reason
why when you see
um [ __ ] 3po and r2d2 crash there's a
giant
skeleton of a worm thing on tatooine
because direct reference direct
reference so yeah there's elements of
this that you've seen before
but this is the source this is the
mother's milk of that kind of thing and
it's
denny villeneux who is so awesome
uh i i it's it's i i mean
it looks exactly like i hoped it would
um it's not like oh my god this is
[ __ ]
recreating it looks like like his
special effects look like the shots in a
rival
like where you know he's not going in
close on [ __ ] like look at these wides
with giant [ __ ] spaceships hanging in
the air that don't look like the normal
spaceships
you know the spaceships you're
accustomed to the thing that i loved
about the lynch movie is that hey it's
david lynch and so it's weird as [ __ ]
but it's the first like movie about
aliens
that looks alien to me like none of it
looked like [ __ ] that i'd seen before
none of it looked like star wars which
every movie post star wars looked like
that
agreed you know and so it just and their
[ __ ] guild navigators look like crazy
giant space vaginas i wonder what
they'll look like this time yeah i hope
they're crazy giant space vaginas
because otherwise denis
why do we get a french canadian if
you're not going to do crazy french
canadian [ __ ]
um so he's sequalized blade runner he's
making remaking dune what else from the
80s would we like denis to tackle
um i bet you return to the jedi
i bet you there's a there's a repo man
that denny
could could [ __ ] kill that's true be
very expensive though
he likes to make big movies he would it
would be a small character piece
oh jc's got a thought what about last
starfighter [ __ ]
yes goddammit jc what a great idea the
last
starfighter in the hands of denny
villeneuve oh
taking on [ __ ] zura and the kodan
armada
[ __ ] in man take all my [ __ ] money
and throw it at your face
the never-ending story oh
even [ __ ] better i mean [ __ ] you jc
[Laughter]
both great suggestions ladies and
gentlemen uh give denny villeneux
everything
give him whatever he wants maybe not a
marvel movie
he's very dreamy his style i don't know
those movies are
you know but then again
they gave you know taika ytd one and he
turned it into gold so
yeah i mean give him anything he's a
talented director give that man what he
wants
yeah pay that man his marvel
um i'm sure he's like i don't want to do
no marvel i'm doing [ __ ] dune man
yeah i'm gonna do dune for the rest of
my life he's gonna do because there's
more than one doing right
there's i mean there's like nine books
and there's a series that i think they
were talking about doing
um yeah you know had been in development
for a while i don't know what's
happening with it
but it was supposed to be like movie tv
season movie
tv season not sure about the tv season
but we're definitely getting a movie
when is this movie coming i hear the end
of the year uh yeah it's
it's still it's still on track
for an early december release there was
a there was a for a
heartbeat there was a chance that wonder
woman was moving which it is to december
is vacating its october 2nd release date
um
and dune which is scheduled for december
18th thought was also going to move into
2021 but no
warner brothers is keeping both of them
in december so
wonder woman and dune in december yes so
warner brothers seems to think we'll be
out from under by then
they they are hoping what do they know
that we don't
i don't know i'll tell you what those
the tenant uh
returns in america definitely tell the
tale of why wonder woman moved
yeah i think i think there was always
going to be some giant canary in the
coal mine
that's the one you know it wasn't going
to be doing well overseas but here it's
just like it made
20 million in like 10 days yeah which
isn't great but
again kevin smith money i think chris
nolan money i did see on
the on the instagram that there were
people who like yeah we drove down to
san diego to see tenant for my birthday
i'm like what good for you i i look i i
ain't gonna judge it because of his
black widow
i'd do the same but not uh
that's not i'm i look forward to seeing
it but i was not like
a [ __ ] risk the deadly covid
yeah to get that in my eyeballs yeah to
be confused by another nolan movie
[Laughter]
i will go out risk life and death to
feel dumb in a movie theater
i could feel dumb at home thank you uh
what else we got
um i you know we talked earlier in this
particular quarantine that my big
binge show was the walking dead yeah and
i finally uh caught up to it i'm up to
date you're like i can't wait for all
the new seasons because they'll
never end it's gonna go dead forever
brother yeah cut two yeah hello what's
that now forever
no no oh it's done well we're finished
so we're canceled
yes uh season 11 is going to be the last
time the dead walk and they're doing 22
episodes like a big full season big fat
full season
they are i mean the they right now
already owe us like a finale for season
10.
right um the announced season 11 will be
its last will be super sized to 24
episodes up from the traditional 16 24
yes to stretch over two years so
oh boy it's a [ __ ] share farewell
tour is it indeed
it's yeah when you never stop the music
yeah it's just gonna keep on going for a
while but
you believe in life after death by the
end of 2022
we will see the end of the flagship
walking dead show
but how long will it have been with us
that would be uh
400 years pretty much yes they're going
to spin off
they are spinning off the carolyn daryl
show my name's daryl
this is my lady carol this is my other
friend carol
uh good for them smart i mean everybody
loves them you don't need the rest of
those
characters they keep adding new people
to show but everyone loves the
ogs and everyone loves those too they do
you know and then they've had some
relatively high profile departures from
the show i mean
rick left and glenn left and apparently
michonne
leaves um which i didn't get that far so
thanks for spoiling [ __ ] for me the news
the news
the news is [ __ ] [ __ ] up for me hate
news you know and after a while
an ensemble that big gets expensive
yeah you know like every year everybody
gets a raise and after a while
you're like hey this is awesome but
we're spending a god
sum of money yeah this ain't fun anymore
because it's too expensive and also the
audience is like
right the audience is continually going
down from where
it's high of like 20 million people yeah
like every show has
uh sort of you know attrition of an
audience
mated with a an increase in expense for
production
and there will always be a sweet spot at
which it no longer makes sense to make
the show
and even though like walking dead had
been a the best show
and the most watched show on tv for a
stretch
then sunk to the best most watched show
on cable
and then this past season it was like
[ __ ] you we're yellowstone we are now
the most watched show on cable which is
crazy
which is nuts and so as that decline
happens and the expense rises
i think they were like yeah no we'll
we'll end this story and i'm not saying
it's crazy because it's dog [ __ ] i
haven't watched it but i'm like
yellowstone with [ __ ] costner is the
like the new dallas is the [ __ ]
biggest show on tv
um um good for them that's on paramount
that's on the powerman network
and so they got a hit they had a massive
hit they got a mess of bit and then yeah
that
that demographic has not failed cbs
which is like
older white people really like tv shows
about
cows and cowboys and internal drama on
the prairie i suppose true
but yes so we're gonna get the carolyn
darryl show which i really hope is a
variety show because god i love like the
carol and daryl hour
that'd be amazing like singing and
dancing and like hog tie and stuff mr
robert goulet
singing the actual theme song by bear
mccreary to the walking dead
oh my god i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
i'm good um so yes we are getting fear
the walking dead which is returning for
its sixth season in like
a month um the two season lemonade
series the walking still happening huh
fear is still happening um the what what
he did amc cancels no shows except for
comic book man
geez man uh the world beyond which is
starting up
on uh god geez even sooner than free of
the walking dead it's a two season
limited series
then you're going to get the [ __ ]
carol and daryl mystery uh machine tour
carol and daryl mysteries we would have
got away with it too if we're
these [ __ ] zombies totally uh
apparently there's an anthology show
that they're working on
developing too much look you can't be
like we're finishing the one show
so we could start five others yes
yeah um and then and also you know what
to be fair
you know they've they've ruled the
zombie roost for a nice long time
sounds like zack snyder about to rule it
himself with the netflix zombie movies
that he's doing so
it might be a nice time for these cats
to
yeah take a breather sometimes just you
know take your winnings
yeah and there's nothing but win [ __ ]
all of it
yeah robert kirkman just laughing at
everybody from heaven and i don't mean
he's dead i just mean
his life is heaven because he's [ __ ]
super rich because of his comic book
yeah he owns [ __ ] heaven yeah
publishes comic books out of it
yeah you didn't know there was an island
in the maldives called heaven and he
just bought it he owns it
um well that's good for them yes lots
more walking dead if you were like
feeling like you were gonna miss it
wildly enough walking dead ending but
still
lots more walking yes more than ever
before yeah really farewell walking dead
they're really making up for canceling
the walking dead by giving us five other
[ __ ] shows about it
um doom patrol this did drop today
more news on a saturday uh news that
came out of the dc
fandom part two yes uh is that doom
patrol is getting a season three on the
hbo max i expected nothing less this
show is very buzzy
uh has very dedicated fan base and uh is
it a berlanti show
it is indeed uh yeah i i
i'm not surprised by this at all i'm
sure they saw how well it was doing
from the launch of hbo max forward it
had been on
you know it probably still is the dc
universe app but
yeah which is not like the myspace of
streaming apps
sadly but uh once they got a load of
you know how many people were watching
i'm sure they were like keep it [ __ ]
going
yeah we got our own umbrella academy
let's go
and also there's there's not a ton of
fresh superhero content on hbo max
um like all the stuff that like there's
a green lantern show that's coming
you know there's there's the the bad
robot kind of
justice league dark stuff coming but a
lot of it is
not even in production oh it's way far
away so two years minimum
so they're looking if you're looking to
scratch that itch and you're a viewer
and a subscriber
this will happily scratch that edge for
you [ __ ] a man have you watched it
yet
i haven't i'm not [ __ ] weird we do
the show and neither of us have really
dug deep on it my kid loves it yeah i i
i was i was torn between the time i'm
you know what i'm gonna make the [ __ ]
time
give us a report back next week i will
because i loved
the doom patrol comic book that uh grant
morrison did back in the day
it was fantastic and from what i
understand they take a lot of their cues
right from it
yeah like i had to keep leaning because
i'm [ __ ] exhausted
i had room in my life for one
dysfunctional family superhero team
at a clip and i i chose and not for any
reason did i choose one versus the other
but i flipped a coin and landed on
umbrella academy
so that's what i'm into now and then
when i'm done with that i'll swirl back
in
um mark's up to date with the boys which
dropped a
four on friday four dropped like
thursday night friday morning whatever
it is
i gotta watch that one oh man it uh
there's
takes a jump in this episode it takes a
[ __ ] job believe me i was into the
first
three but sounds like four is where the
plot really kicks in
the the back half of the third episode
you know which i hadn't seen last time
we sat down and chatted
you know does absolutely kick it into
gear where it's you know compound v and
the secret is out and what the [ __ ] are
we gonna do and
you know the whole like kamiko's brother
and huey and star like all that stuff is
it comes to a head
in the third episode in a way that i
liked but four
like suddenly becomes in the way that
lovecraft country is and the way that
that watchman was
becomes a show about today in a way that
i don't even know if they could have
preceded predicted when it was going on
no way but
well i mean if they're borrowing from
the boys and the boys they did
stormfront
as a guy i believe um and
you know that the stormfront was what
stormfront was
in the books i think too yeah you know
and i i ain't taking anything away from
kripke and [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] wonderful guy and a genius uh
and this show is fantastic
but right there there's some roots to
this there's some roots of that you know
and and
i haven't i read like the first arc of
the boys and didn't continue
beyond there um but it's uh
yeah no it it goes in a place that i
didn't expect it to go but should have
given the name stormfront which
is not without a certain amount of
baggage um
but also the commentary on sort of media
and social media and the power
of celebrity and you know and it's even
[ __ ] politically relevant where
you know [ __ ] homelanders like there
are 50 million people who like me
and she's like you don't need 50 million
people you can't win everybody
you have 50 million fans i have 5
million soldiers and which one of those
is more valuable
and it's like oh [ __ ] this might as well
be a campaign conversation
you can't win the entire country you
just have to win the ones who already
agree with you
yeah oh damn i was looking for a good
time yeah i didn't i wasn't i look to
watch my shows to get away from politics
sounds like i'm gonna dive right into it
indeed like a giant sperm whale
um yeah which they did last week [ __ ]
what a delightful show i can't wait to
dive into it new
uh raised by wolves dropping as well and
new lovecraft country tomorrow
yes and the nexium dock the vow is also
a new episode just tomorrow [ __ ]
creepy i'm one behind
i'm the branding wait till you get to
three
where they talk to that [ __ ] girl
who's like incredibly intelligent
like you know and i don't say that
because i'm like she's a girl and she's
smart i
most [ __ ] cult people people
get trapped wrapped up in a cult you
know generally
there's some weakness that can be
exploited i guess
and that's you know when you hear them
talk you're like oh they're [ __ ]
cultists
she sounds completely [ __ ] rational
and logical just like the other guy mark
vicente
and still they [ __ ] got duped into
this
um so yeah that's been pretty
fascinating to watch
yeah and i'm all about it all about it
um what else we got
um mgm television is uh
seems to want to make a robocop show
with that robocop
in it i heard rumor of this yeah
so would that be mcmurphy before he
becomes
no they don't seem to care about murphy
at all it's all about dick jones the
rise of dick jones and the taking over
of omni consumption
the whole show is about dick jones you
don't know
so that means he built is that what it's
called it should be that that's a
brilliant title
so it's him building the ed 209 or
whatever to follow
it's uh ed neumeyer one of the originals
uh robocop's writer spoke with a site
called moviehold and revealed that a
robocop adjacent series is in the works
about the rise of dick jones and omni
consumer products
uh the shady company which served the
center of power of detroit in the
original movie
it has all the cool stuff about robocop
except no robocop neumeyer said
which feels weird yeah it's weird i mean
i know they did smallville did superman
without superman
and gotham did most of batman without
batman right
but did you ever see there was a show on
robocop this is your titular lead um
there's a show on fox i want to say in
the early 90s called profit did you ever
see it
no i'm adrian pasdar oh i remember the
show
yes but it was about ultimately a
sociopath
who goes to work at some giant companies
it was in the [ __ ] 90s where
late 80s early 90s was all like cocaine
gordon gekko and
wall street and everything is glorious
as long as it's greedy
and it was about how this broken man
becomes a wizard on wall street and the
corporate structure
by ultimately being a sociopath and it
was kind of fascinating just like this
study of a morality
and the pursuit of profit if you did
something like that with dick jones if
it's like succession meets robocop or
billions meets robocop then
all right you know [ __ ] it maybe granted
i eventually want to see a giant [ __ ]
you know
whaled-nosed cannon mounting chassis
shooting [ __ ] in boardrooms but
okay you know in the hands of somebody a
good writer it could be something it's
gonna be weird though do a robocop show
with that robocop but ballsy
right like you know you know how good
the show's gonna be we don't need
robocop
you're like really all right but it also
becomes why does it have to be
a robocop like it could just be like
because man
and you know as well as i exactly why
that is
if you were to start a brand new thing
and call it the brand new thing
you got a a road to a road a hoe
there's a lot of work ahead of you
because you gotta make the whole [ __ ]
world
hear about it and get excited about it
and want to spend the money on it and
[ __ ] and there's a lot of [ __ ]
competition for attention these days
the [ __ ] dropping all the time there's
too much content to keep up with
so their rationale is like hey man
anything gives us this much of an edge
like playing in the robocop adjacent
[ __ ] sphere
that lifts us up over [ __ ] 200 shows
that have to start dry
so i i get it i mean it's not my way but
i get it yeah i mean i i get it but then
there's also the version of
i was told this was a robocop show
and it seems to be a bunch of dudes in
boardrooms talking about [ __ ]
they were like well that happened in
robocop but there was also
a robot cop where's that melty
[ __ ]
that's what you need the show should be
about him yes unless somebody's gonna
say i buy that for a dollar
every 10 minutes then i'm going to be
let down by said program sir
i saw somebody tweeted like uh what's
the name of the bad guy
moniker what is it clarence botticker
clarence
they said uh i want the [ __ ] this
pre-story
to be about how clarence went from like
a dad in the suburbs
to this crazy killer and they had a
picture of him from that 70s show
next to him is [ __ ] clarence i think
yeah
yeah how how bogamill from beverly hills
cop
went from like well-meaning police chief
in california
to corporate raider in detroit that's
true that's true
man my god he was his [ __ ] that was
axel foley's buddy
he totally was what a good actor he
could go from being like [ __ ] the
good guy to being the shitty ass bad guy
and deliverance as well my god what a
career man oh ronnie cox
you know what megan is he still around
um i don't think he is i think he passed
away last year did he really somebody
look it up
standing by um yeah let's hold folks
when we find out
yeah what is his name again ronnie cox
ronnie cox
that's right he was in [ __ ]
deliverance good call andrew
we looking really i thought he passed
good stop killing ronnie cox
protect what is it guard the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
of all the coxes we need to see [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] shot i want to see today
yes bring them up
[ __ ] uh we just talked ourselves into
watching that show
we did it we went from like it ain't got
robocop to like ronnie cox
ronnie cox if it's like old ronnie cox i
remember when i first got to detroit and
they get us all i'm telling you that's
how they [ __ ]
win is by like open with him as an
old-timer didn't isn't that what they
were supposed to do with
indiana jones adventures the young
indiana jones yeah like you'd see a
little bit of old man like but they
never did that did they
did it like once harrison ford thing
yeah like
oh it wasn't harrison ford it was a guy
playing i thought there was one they got
they got actual harrison i don't
remember that but i do remember this
remember it was a cabin in the woods
episode that had harrison in it yeah
just one
as indiana jones yeah i believe he was
indiana but the
recurring like the old old man is like
some guy with an eye patch
some other guy oh [ __ ] they took his eye
out yeah so they said somewhere along
the lines he got [ __ ] an eye plucked
out yeah
when we gonna see that [ __ ] movie
well it happened on the lip of the
fridge when he dived into it
[ __ ] fruit crisper hit him in the eye
and he was like ah
um all right where are we going next we
are going out of space [ __ ] yeah
that's where i wanna look nobody wants
to be on this [ __ ] planet anymore
let's go to space
you know who's going to [ __ ] space
apparently who um have you started
watching the fast and furious
not yet i'm gonna soon i've been uh
they're going to space man
cars in space cars like they're gonna
drift in space
one parsec at a time i i can't even come
and i have to watch these movies to
understand how the [ __ ] any of this is
possible
it is impossible watching the movies
does not lead you to believe that them
in space make sense
and i want it so badly sounds like
moonraker
yeah and how is that a bad habit
good excellent point apparently michelle
rodriguez who plays lady ortiz in the
fast and furious series
was speaking to siriusxm's jess cagle
uh and co-host of the uh julia
cunningham on the just giggle show
and teammates ew right he was eddie w
and people he was my boss
once upon a time lo these many years ago
what does he do now um he's the host of
this show on
[ __ ] series and i guess he's rich
oh is he it must be or are they people
like you gotta be rich to work it's
serious they don't pay
[ __ ] others are paying a king's ransom
all right so what did she say anyway she
seemingly confirmed that fast nine will
be sending some of its stars to space
um because ludicrous apparently uh
not one for keeping secrets had
previously mentioned uh in an interview
that uh that they might be going to
space and luda was like i don't know
where you heard that
i'm gonna say one of the things you said
is right
wink wink space so not in nine but it
would be in ten
it would be somewhere else down the line
or what maybe
jason voorhees went to space why can't
the fast kids go to space
i mean like space is the final frontier
and at this point they've done
everything else
hey look i ain't saying [ __ ] because
five like when we do the next j and
sound bob sequel
space yeah taking them off [ __ ] terra
firma taking them into the stars you
know [ __ ] like suspended animation
they go to sleep one day and wake up and
oh no i'm just gonna rip off last
starfighter before denny villeneuve does
it
same [ __ ] story we're good at video
games then we get taken to [ __ ]
nice where is it like we stole it
already for the clerk's cartoon we did
an episode where
randall was good at playing a game
called pharaoh and then somebody was
like
come with us and uh they were like uh
he's like are you gonna use my special
skills to fight in wars and i'm like no
you're gonna
move rocks because that's all the game
was about was building a pyramid
um all right it's a tale as old as time
it is or 1983.
such a good story and you know what it
doesn't get its proper due someone will
remake that movie
we almost had gary wida on to talk about
it because
once upon a time he was chasing the
rights something fears to do it
and there's one of the screenwriters who
won't let it go is that right i think
that's
like rogan wanted to do it spielberg
wanted to do it
really there's a long line of people
like let's [ __ ] remake last
starfighter
and they can't get their rights to do it
why the writer's just like nah
i'm happy with what we did yeah fine
really yeah how honorable
not to be like give me that sweets last
starfighter
the last check instead my man's just
like nah
i got a little i like to spend a little
thing called integrity
[Music]
and it's bought me all of this mobile
home
by the way i hope he has a huge estate
this van down by the river
look at it who says no to spielberg let
me tell you something spielberg could be
like
i'm making the next chain song baba
billy you sure are captain
can't wait to see it it's gonna be
magical it's gonna be a shot where
somebody stands and the camera rises
with him i know that
but i think it's one of those in the
same way that spielberg always wanted to
make a james bond movie and they
wouldn't give him the right so it makes
indiana jones
he wanted to make last star fighter
couldn't get the rights he makes ready
player one
which is like i gotta scratch my kid
really good at video games goes on crazy
adventure it's inspired by video games
not a one-to-one ratio though it isn't
but it's close
yeah yeah last starfighter is a classic
ready player one book is a classic
movie's gonna take a minute or two to
reach that but that last starfighter
[ __ ]
that story still works people steal it
all the time they do
um so yes fast and furious is going to
space and i could not be happier and i
can't wait until we get you to watch
promise by the time they go to space i
will have watched all
on all the entries prior to that on the
on the fast and by curious podcast that
you and i do
fasted by curious excellent [ __ ] name
we shall do that that's a good [ __ ]
that name's good enough to do that
how many movies are there there's going
to be nines eight plus
hobbs and shaw plus hops and shots so
there's nine in the series oh my god so
nothing yeah and then our tenth episode
will be when the real the next movie
comes fast nine see all we gotta do is
and we also don't have to keep going
[ __ ] cereal didn't
cereal stopped like that blew my mind i
was like you could just stop
podcasting i thought once you started
you had to go until you died
apparently this story has an ending yeah
who knew uh
so yeah we're that is fast and by
curious
um what else we got um daisy ridley
yeah this was big [ __ ] news this was
big [ __ ] news the internet got very
angry yet again
indeed she did an interview with josh
gad who was guest hosting jimmy kimmel
and revealed that uh at first she was
told
during the force awakens prep and even
shooting
that ray was going to be related to ben
kenobi
what huh that would have made a lot of
sense
it would have made a ton of sense
although some people online were like
no i like it better than she was her own
person right and then in the second
movie it was
ryan came in and said you know what no
here's what i want i want her to be ray
nobody
she's got no parents no i do and it's
just hey you know what she's just
an ordinary person who parents [ __ ]
sold you for drug money say drug money
but he said didn't they
say or whatever yeah like they're
indicated that her parents are no damn
good
yeah and uh and and it seems as if
looking at the internet reaction to this
most people preferred
the rain nobody version of it yeah maybe
minus the whole
skywalker my name is now skywalker
that that seemed to hit people in a bad
way it did
um so her quote is at the beginning they
were toying with one i found very weird
about it wasn't so much her going like
sky walker
was the rando in the middle of the
desert going
what's your name it's like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] move on lady
before i whip out my lightsaber and cut
you up you don't need to know my name
yeah but if you're curious it's just
skywalker she just snaps his neck from
afar using the force yeah
tell me what is your don't be so [ __ ]
nosy
yeah that's my name my name is like
you've been force choked
yeah i know my name is choke the [ __ ] up
um yeah uh at the beginning they were
toying with an obi-wan connections
why didn't she just jedi mind trick that
chick you don't need to know my name
she really wanted to tell somebody she
did she was like oh thank god you're
here
skywalker it's like she's a she's a
little kid at a [ __ ]
uh like tourist store uh souvenir shop
looking for like skywalker on the
license plates and doesn't have it and
she goes
excuse me do you have a skywalker back
there
my name is ray skywalker and they're
like oh oh oh really oh
like the legendary luke i see no but
we've got a ray
[ __ ] your ray i want a sky wolf do you
have as many midi cloridians in your
blood as
he had in his uh so yes
she uh at first was told that there was
going to be an ob1 connection
and then it comes to the first movie and
yes and then there was like
no connection whatsoever then it really
went to it was no one
and then it came to episode nine and jj
pitched me the film and was like oh yeah
palpatine is granddaddy
then two weeks later he was like oh
we're not sure so it kept changing so
even as we were filming i wasn't sure
what the answer was going to be
which everyone on the internet literally
guessed
that when the movie came out they were
all like this movies
i feel like they added stuff the last
minute there was like a
news item that was out when the movie
was coming out where they talked about
like she looped some lines like [ __ ]
two weeks before
they locked pictures something like that
so everyone was like they never had a
plan they're just figuring out as they
went along and it also sounds like
i don't know how this [ __ ] happened
but it sounds like maybe
like jj did not have final cut on that
picture
i mean i he's not come out and said that
but he has come out and said it but it
does seem as if
you know jj the way he likes to work
is he likes to be on a tightrope you
know like when when he's
you know lost was that way i think a lot
of alias was that way
um and i think he's gotten to to believe
that like maybe if it's not that way i
won't do my best work like i need that
pressure
that's how he does it of the danger of
we could all fall down and collapse and
i could see that putting on a big show
and so
keeping these things alive and keeping
them you know always kind of
out of focus in the edges you know for
him maybe that leads him to believe that
there's going to be genius in the middle
of all this madness
but i can see how it would make it
really hard for an actor to play a role
not knowing who that role is especially
if that character's story is all about
identity yeah and it's all about
who am i who was like look [ __ ] the
mystery box
tell me something about my character so
i could play this i mean and not every
character requires that like i don't
give a [ __ ] who james bond's parents
were i don't
i didn't need to know that indiana jones
had parents
i'm glad they eventually showed me his
dad that's kind of cool but
we named the dog indiana totally
but like mailed it to the market to play
indiana jones
he knows who he is he knows where he's
from and that is not an open question
and if this characters hold res on
detroit french
uh is who am i and who am i in this
world yes
you have to have that answer going in to
give that actor so they can play so that
the
the structure of the movie actually
makes sense
and if you don't then you're at the risk
of plummeting off the edge and voila
which is also french
um would you have preferred herbie ray
kenobi
um i i liked that version of it i think
we even talked about it early on was
like what are we [ __ ] badass if she
was related to kenobi
um because that's the answer you don't
expect you expect a skywalker
you expect that lineage because that's
what these [ __ ] movies are about
kenobi was a was a sort of curveball
which i dug
but i also completely got behind she's
nobody because you know what
most people are nobody yeah and most
people coming to this movie
want to see themselves in it in a
certain way i also thought that scene
was really dope when he was just like
you're nobody
you don't matter he literally didn't he
said like you don't matter to the story
or some such [ __ ] where you're like is
he is the world reviewing the movie
without you in it happily um yeah man i
thought that was pretty dark that was a
nice twist to pull
yeah um but as we all know now
she's not nobody no she's [ __ ] still
related to palpatine no
yeah so why is everybody like i like it
better when she was nobody
oh that was for ryan's movie right but
at the end she's
she's yeah yeah all right so it was good
when she was nobody it was bad from in
rise of skywalker
from palpatine yeah because you have to
then resurrect palpatine who was dead
and gooden did yeah and like the body
was he was the last guy
left you know they got they even brought
nine of them back they're like we're not
gonna bring the emperor back
everybody gets a victory left everybody
comes back
um we have two endings um one is way
sadder than the other uh as our final
stories
um did you ever watch the venture
brothers yeah of course
funny yeah i quite liked the venture
brothers uh the venture
for like 17 years it's they they
they did seven seasons in 17 years
which wasn't a thing i was aware that
you could get away with yeah that's
that's a glacial pace it is i mean
sopranos was taking the record for like
we're gonna go two years between these
seasons but when we come back it's gonna
be [ __ ]
oh look at the tits and i like venture
brothers kind of soup to nuts but
that level of commitment to a show is is
unprecedented and and now no longer
going on adult swim has officially
pulled a plug
why i ask in a world where they
make the show every nine years why not
just continue
i think that that perhaps for them you
know and even
watching the show as a fan that i was it
is so fundamentally not the show that it
was
um and that audience is now it's like
the beginning of harry potter like there
are there are kids who
have been born started watching cartoons
and then stopped watching cartoons
in the run of this show that's true and
so you know staying
relevant as an idea for that long
with so little space between like sure
simpson can go for 40 [ __ ] years
but every september you're getting a
season of the simpsons very true and
but like if you don't get a season of
venture brothers in four years
like how do you continue and maintain
any level of
momentum other than it being a surprise
for those die hard fans who love a thing
so true um but so adult swim said they
were canceling it
everybody involved was like we get it
but we're super sad because we were in
the middle of writing season eight
um and can't wait to get ready and oh is
that right
um so it seems as if perhaps there might
be an hbo max play
um to continue the venture brothers
um who's the dude the actor
james urbaniac so damn good
yeah um a fave of mine from uh hal
hartley's stuff but
oh he was wonderful on this show as well
but yeah i mean there's well
congratulations kids i wish you could
keep going and it sounds like it may
actually keep going
it may actually keep going nothing ever
dies uh all in entertainment now
all entertainment is like a marvel or dc
character nobody ever really dies
it's just waiting for the inevitable
reboot yeah um so yes thank you venture
brothers go team venture
for those seven seasons in 17 years
i wish i knew how you got away with that
but well done well done
wait a way to pull one over on the man i
mean
they went longer than johnny quest the
show that they're making fun of
like johnny quest was a couple seasons
yeah these cats did
17 17 years um and the other farewell
is for dame diana rigg ah bittersweet
farewell
indeed the english actress i'm appeal
i'm appeal
the original avengers and lady oleana
yeah game of thrones she
i remember she [ __ ] like you know
confessed to killing joffrey and [ __ ]
yes so good dope um she's also in
muppets take manhattan
she's done a lot of work in her 82 years
yeah um her last role apparently was in
an edgar wright movie
oh last night in soho which i think
which is coming out soon
coming out either this year or next year
unclear
as with all release dates but uh but
yeah she
she had herself a relatively uh glorious
storied career
um she died she was diagnosed with
cancer i believe it was back in march
and according to her daughter my beloved
mom died peacefully in her sleep early
this morning at home surrounded by her
family
she was diagnosed in march and spent her
last months joyfully reflecting on her
extraordinary life full of love laughter
and a deep pride in her profession
i will miss her beyond words wow man
tough to lose a parent especially one
that you like that much
apparently what uh how old uh 82.
i mean hell of a long wonderful life but
still
i mean you know she was in game of
thrones what last year two years ago
yeah i mean and she still looked so damn
vital
um and it's one of those things where
like would you rather
know you were going to pass or would you
rather be a surprise
and it seems as if for her knowing that
she was going to pass
gave her the opportunity to close all of
these circles
and she's true and to you know say
goodbye to those she wanted to say
goodbye to
and and reflect on a life well lived and
sort of bask in the in the in the short
time
that she had left we all go kids i mean
none of us get to stay
and so just make sure that you fill
every damn day
chasing your damn dreams you know
sometimes you gotta actually
work but other times every day
chase that [ __ ] dream because it just
stops
it just [ __ ] stops man and if you're
lucky you get 82 [ __ ] years
a brilliant career man i mean you know
it's
the way i see this business i've said it
before
very much like high school and you know
there are popular kids
and she was a popular kid for her entire
[ __ ] career
you know that kind of longevity tough to
pull off in this business
not a lot of people make it all the way
to the end uh still
working you know leave a [ __ ] set
toes up or whatever
um so good for her good for diana rigg
man thank you for all the entertainment
that you gave us
thank you for being an appeal indeed
thank you being tracy bond
she was she was jealous that's right she
was george lassenby's woman indeed she
was she was the one
the one bond wife who married james bond
who gets killed
who died as a result in the next movie
right now she dies because the end of
that movie you're right
and the following movie picks up a
[ __ ] legendary career roger moore at
the gravesite the gravestone
yeah oh my god [ __ ]
i forgot that's [ __ ] crazy what did
that how did they handle that with uh
homeboy the guy yeah do they
is he meant to be roger moore and he's
meant to yeah i mean there is
skyfall is the movie that kind of wraps
its arms around the entirety of the
so does that mean that he had a wife
that got killed it means that at some
point that character did indeed have a
wife who died
um like he goes he goes back to his
[ __ ] shed that he keeps all of his
like memorabilia in and there's the old
aston martin
and there's all these trophies of his
past deeds and he goes to his wife's
grave
yeah and he goes to he goes to the
ancestral mansion
you know skyfall and i think an early
version of that story was supposed to be
it was a retirement home for james bonds
oh and
and they wanted sean come on they wanted
sean connery to be the albert finney
role and it would have been james bond
is a moniker that we pass from one
person to another
here are all of the rest of them you are
the latest and together you and the old
james bonds will deal with this new
threat is that right
and sean connery couldn't do it and then
once you can't get connery they're like
well
let's just change the story let's just
change it so now he is the one and only
bond and he has had all of these lives
and at the end of his career he's faced
with the next generation
in um what's his face javier bardem
which is not bad either
the new bad guy what's his name remy
malik
yeah he looks like he's going for a
javier bardem kind of villain
yeah very very high culture very kind of
like
operatic hello mr bomb yes hi
i'm wearing a map everybody's ever like
what's up awesome
we're gonna kill you now it's gonna be
hot yeah i i wish bob hoskins could have
been like a bond villain like oh boy
[ __ ] you that's awesome not right back
i'll crush your [ __ ] nuts with this
rope
they did that in the movie didn't they
um no they wailed into the nuts
yeah that is the difference well impact
so what it was like this yeah it was
mads mickelson as opposed to
this well yeah it's underneath he sat
him on a wicker chair
cut out the bottom of the worker chair
and could bang
how many times uh five or six i think
and that didn't crush his nuts well yeah
it did
it's there my favorite thing about that
is that
everybody i love nuts i love when
they're clean-shaven
i love when they
um every bond movie since pussycal are
you gonna be a kidnapped by a [ __ ]
supervillain make sure your balls are
shaved clean
indeed i mean maybe you might want the
padding for impact but if not if it's
for
aesthetic purposes [ __ ] like easter
eggs to get the hair off so that when
that rope comes swinging into your nuts
your nuts are so
smooth it glides right off indeed but
ever since goldfinger
every bond movie has been screened and i
think it's like royal albert hall or
whatever it is
for royalty for like the queen of
england who always made it part of her
thing
to see and the same queen since then
that's true for every james bond movie
she's been the [ __ ] queen totally and
so
there is on her majesty's secret service
there's a ver
there's a reality in which the queen of
england watched daniel craig get whaled
in the balls a lot
probably and i look good
again
i saw a video of her driving and it
really humanized her for me
like she was in a [ __ ] range rover
and she was like taking put on a blinker
made a left i'm like
what the [ __ ] this person's in charge of
the empire they're just driving a car
like a normal ass person and she was
wearing like a hair net like a lady old
ladies wear
it was adorable i was like who knew
she's running out for like a pint of
margarine or something yeah she was just
like i ran out of dog
food you know because she's got all
those dogs there's no more donuts in the
castle
i'm going for a run she's not a [ __ ]
spitting image puppet she's the queen
show some respect
sorry i'm going more like this
hello that's right she sounds exactly
like robin williams
in mrs dobson she is mrs depp well he
was playing a british woman right yeah
he's playing the queen of england he's
playing [ __ ] queen elizabeth we
discovered it right here
um we got questions jc
let's try i'm [ __ ] bushed but all
right
i'm gonna try i'm gonna try to soldier
through some questions at least one here
we go
depends how good they are oh gosh pick a
good one so [ __ ] pick a great one
bring us the thumb okay uh this
is since nate's here and his poster art
for tonight was
men in black that's right uh in the
house here you know we go empty of
course because whatever rules and [ __ ]
but
uh our good friend deacon here and
nate who does all of our [ __ ] artwork
darth vader
motion poster that we had it was it the
first motion poster
today's artwork had the flashing light
all of the artwork that you ever see for
this show nate always does and you can
buy it where
the dark nate returns
and he's got a [ __ ] whole page over
on what t w t
public big cartel which one
t public where you could get all of the
[ __ ] artwork for all the shows we've
done put on a goddamn shirt yeah and
masks also like a fat man beyond logo
yes that's right right [ __ ] did you
ever get one of your shirts with your
[ __ ] printed on it
how is it print
i love too t public rocks um all right
we got a question go ahead
so uh fripp 25 wants to know if you
could neuralize
someone who would it be and what would
you
tell them to change or alter
so if you could pick somebody to
neuralize and then what kind of
living or dead or just living uh just
living like i can't go back in time and
[ __ ] like hey hitler
yeah yeah i feel like we should take
trump off of the
because that's the answer that is the
answer really so weird that it was like
hitler or trump
uh which one but yes i would flashy
thing the president
and then be like you're such a nice man
and all you want to do is help
help help help or or make him think he's
still on set of home alone too
and like not actually president but just
still daughtering around his mansion
waiting for them to shoot
that's true and at least i went for like
give him a second chance like you're a
nice man get it done
most people be like retire
get out yeah i just i i instead want to
trap him in some
never-ending uh image of his own like
he always thinks he's on that set he
always thinks he's banging around trump
plaza let's check with jc and see if
anybody in the chat is like hey
shut your [ __ ] mouths i come here to
be entertained
that's my president no chet
mostly agrees and are flooding with more
questions
so i think we're safe okay good fair
enough um all right
we both say the same answer i mean if
we're saying it can't be trump i gotta
come up with somebody else
i don't know because trump's really good
prime candidate uh what else we got
vitakis wants to know uh
if each of you were to have a lowest
superman kind of relationship where you
were constantly being
rescued which superhero would you want
rescuing you chris evans got a massive
dick
apparently so like you're safe he holds
you in his arms
but then if he loses you the dick
catches you as well so
uh let me see who do i really want i
mean naturally superman because he could
do everything
um and i wouldn't care if it was like
you know i'd be like his
you know superman's pal jimmy olsen it
don't have to be supergirl where i'm
like i need you know [ __ ] a girl
to touch me dude can pick me up by the
nuts for all i care
the shave nuts thanks to manscape.com um
as long as he's saving my ass um
all right so my real answer is
superman why break a [ __ ] good thing
if you're going for the superman lowest
relationship
let me just [ __ ] slide into lois's
place
um or for anybody that's like you can't
pick a dude then
uh zatanna magic right
fishnet stockings big [ __ ] barta
i want big barter to be my hero i want
her to just crazy
you will be [ __ ] cradled like a
little baby
how you doing baby i'm good big barter
where you wanna go now honey i'm gonna
go to the [ __ ] waffle house we're
going to
house the big barter that's my dream
scenario everything somewhere scot-free
is like that's my wife
don't take her to the waffle house and
i'm just like every time i fall out of a
tree
every time i like rob a bank every time
i'm accidentally on the scene of some
hostage crisis
big barta comes and we get waffles good
big barter though not early female
furies big barta you know i can go
i like them when they're mean to me yeah
if she's saving my life and taking me
for waffles i kind of don't care about
her moral
sort of dilemma she got that giant wand
yeah she does
you got that chris evan sized wanda
um guard that [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen
uh all right that's two questions let's
go we're gonna make a third we're gonna
do it
i think we're gonna do questions i was
saying in the beginning of the show
before we started i was like i don't
think we're really good questions i'm
tired
but here we are at the third question
already round and home this is from
uh velen chevan uh
they would like to know what heroes
villains would you hire to work on your
movie set
and then they say i feel like storm
would be a great gaffer
she could make it overcast or make it
magic hour
whenever whenever you need so who would
you guys want on your set
barry allen um
he's a runner [ __ ] everything's gonna
be done fast what would i make him i'd
make him the
i'd make him the ad because the ads got
to run the set make sure everything's
moving fast
who better to trust than the flash
himself
um i would have green lantern because
then you don't have to pay for any
special effects
you know it's long green dude wow
why do you mean [ __ ] won't be
impressed i got green lantern to do [ __ ]
in my movie they're like it's all green
um all right so he does the thing and
then we do a layer and post where we
color whatever it is okay so if he does
a giant baseball myth that's green
in post we make it look like i love that
suddenly you have to have like giant
things like
this is supposed to be like a courtroom
drama why is everything huge
i got [ __ ] green lantern he doesn't
do small [ __ ]
he's he he makes giant baseball gloves
trains out of nowhere things like that
the gavel is the size of a volkswagen
that's not how this works
i would have professor x nice because
then you could communicate to
everybody milwaukee's yes
yes look at that so smart absolutely
you just feel like to me my x-men and
then they come in
to me craft services to me m m's
also if nobody learned their lines he
could just be like this is what you say
yeah that's a [ __ ] filmmaker right
there he's absolutely right man
[ __ ] like you don't have to memorize
lines when you got
[ __ ] professor x on set because he's
just like
snooch to the nooch and then the guy on
camera is like
snooch to the nooch okay he's making my
movie so
obviously jason that's how we're doing
this um what other characters would be
useful for
the cinematic arts in chat they're
calling out mysterio
because you could just shoot in the
black absolutely [ __ ] right
how dumb of me and i wrote that
character and i know his [ __ ]
backstory but i figured i got that cover
of green lantern because he could do
anything with his ring but fair enough
absolutely quentin beck
and i'd elevate him to a high position
so he wouldn't get all shitty and turn
into mysterio i'd treat him good
i'd hit him with the flashy thing and be
like you're good you want to help people
you're a good person so basically hitler
trump
and mysterio are the three people that
we would flashy thing
um what about you build your movie uh
the only thing that comes to mind is uh
mad drock's the multiple man to be all
of the extras
crowd scenes yes oh my goodness more of
you
that's crazy you put on a hat you put on
some gloves you could shoot during a
quarantine with him
as all the extras that you only got to
give him one test that's fantastic
oh my god what a great pull are there
any other x-men well we got professor x
we got
professor x jamie madrox what else you
[ __ ] need um
and as suggested storm
on lights i feel like forge could also
like
build everything granted it's not magic
green
giant [ __ ] but i feel like that's a dude
who could fabricate anything you needed
true this um
i mean hell tony stark is basically a
one person ilm
or just get doctor strange yeah just
[ __ ] magic dude
everything you don't even need cameras
like we need a camera he's like
done it's like are those reels of film
you're my major movie for you
he's like reels of film what year are
you making this movie in
digital i like my [ __ ]
digital i'm like doctor strange has a
real deep voice
and he's very passionate about digital
filmmaking it's faster you're a dick
doctor strange yeah
calm down man why don't you go not
operate on somebody doc he's uh
he's not one of those cats it's like you
gotta shoot on 35 millimeter
yeah he's not the nolan of uh of
sorcerer supreme him and bariana
about barry allen are like we got to go
fast so
[ __ ] digital is fine chad's calling
out mystique
because you don't need to pay like
robert downey jr anymore to be iron man
you pay mystique
and she can be everywhere oh what a good
point man that's shape shifter you could
have mystique playing
very famous people you could have
mystique play robert shaw from jaws even
though he's been dead for like 30 years
oh yeah like she's absolutely going to
be fred astaire and marilyn monroe she
could bring back
all the greats and stuff [ __ ]
this is a good idea get mystique on the
horn we're making movies
why can't david blaine do that [ __ ] you
know what you know what those movies are
going to be
rated x oh thank you get it
because we're gonna need a bigger boat
there you are
um was that the third and final question
yeah we're good look at that man we did
our jobs ladies and gentlemen we came
here we did it we told you what the [ __ ]
was going on in the world
the unimportant news we talked a lot
about chris evans dick
yeah and we [ __ ] shouted out our good
friends at manscaped.com
for sponsoring tonight's show go to
manscape.com use the code word
fat man all one word they can give you
twenty percent off you're gonna have
some shaved nuts
sounds appetizing doesn't it shave them
then roast them
salt them and then eat them just don't
crush them
nope never that never crushed
um what else can we tell you i'm well
there won't be a show next week ladies
yes you're going back east i am heading
back east to the
motherland if you will new jersey uh
we're opening up
movies the movies pop up in red bank and
then on friday night uh movies are sold
out but friday night
me and jay are doing uh jay and silent
bob get old's 10th anniversary show
it's been 10 years we've been doing that
podcast um at
uh the drive-in in um homedale
in jersey tickets at seasmod.com if
you're on the east coast and you want to
see that sort of thing
man let's do an informal poll how many
people
are on the east coast want to see that
sort of thing tell jc in chat
so that afterwards no we'll wait
i'll just check afterwards um you got
anything
going on uh no man i i'm just
no more hamburger no more chicken eating
no more [ __ ] contests
uh i'm i'm flat out of brackets to do i
feel as if
you know it was you ever seen that show
man versus food
i'm familiar with it you know it used to
be adam richmond who used to go to like
and just do these massive tests
eating you know [ __ ] i'm gonna go
here eat like 98 chicken wings and i'm
gonna go here and eat this eight pound
burger dream job
it's a dream job except that like
according to him it was playing havoc
with his health because he would balloon
up by like 40 pounds
over the course of you know two months
of production and then the diet to take
it all off
and then another season comes in and
he's eating all this [ __ ] every [ __ ]
week
and so he eventually quit the show and
another dude took over but
the the i didn't do any favors to my
health by doing
that right you know i was like you're
doing your brackets yeah like every
other day man [ __ ] fried chicken
showing up
not not awesome for the cholesterol
wonderful for the [ __ ] palate
oh wonderful for the heart not the heart
really but the heart the figurative
heart not the literal heart
yes it was fried chicken for the soul um
where i needed chicken soup for the
heart
to mend you after all that fried food so
so yeah taking a break on that [ __ ]
but you know still [ __ ] working still
[ __ ] podcasting you know living that
dream
we are we are indeed all living that
dream we're all above ground
let's celebrate it's [ __ ] saturday
night my wife before i left she was just
like
i can't believe it's friday i was like i
can't either because it's [ __ ]
saturday
and she was like what i was like yeah
you missed friday completely i build my
fridays around you doing that podcast
you didn't do that podcast yeah i was
like no we did it on saturday night
again next week no show because i'll be
in jersey but the week after that
we'll be back to [ __ ] to
guard that [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen
that's our jobs as instructed by a
captain america himself
indeed that's not just a meme that's an
order yeah that's [ __ ] that's a way
of life
it's philosophy that's a mantra regard
that [ __ ]
um thanks for being here man thanks to
of course
jc for letting us uh hang out in this
here establishment the scum and villainy
cantina thank
andrew in the back switching around and
stuff and always
coming through with good commentary
thanks for resurrecting ronnie cox
yes [ __ ] hey well done uh deacon
and nate hanging out here man thanks to
them for showing up whatnot but most of
all thanks to you ladies well most of
all thanks to manscape because they gave
us money
but second thanks to you ladies and
gentlemen we would thank you first if
you gave us money but we have this free
thing going on and we're not going to
presume upon that
you don't want to pay for your love no
let's let mans get we just want it
we just want it unconditional give us
your unconditional love kind of love we
deserve
the kind of i forget the rest of this
yeah i couldn't even go there with you
musical youth and donna summer you don't
remember that
no that that you know i i passed a duchy
upon the left-hand side
more smooth pull i'll let you off the
hook for not knowing the other one for
knowing that
um thanks for being here kids we thank
you for paying attention uh every week
you know that one show
not last week's show but of the chadwick
show
we were trending on youtube did we yeah
i saw it just today and
i was flipping through something and all
of a sudden i saw trended on this day
and i was like oh my god
so yeah a bunch of people tuned into
that um
i don't think we'll trend tonight
because all we did was talk about
chris evans dick and you could do that
all day without us you could
then again we're hopped on a trend so
maybe we'll trend too good point man
that's it we're not transcending we're
trend following
or trend trying to [ __ ] catch up
because we're old men if it swells ride
it
yeah that's [ __ ] that's what i
believe what it says under chris evans
picture
it swells right uh ladies and gentlemen
that is all we have for you this evening
go enjoy the rest of your week and i'll
see some of you
in jersey this week on friday i'll see
the rest of you in a couple of weeks
that's right we'll be back right here
telling you more good [ __ ] very very
soon uh within like well two weeks
actually probably two weeks from right
now
um thanks for being here there is no
[ __ ] show
without the dude to my left give it up
for mr mark bernardin
thank you sir and that is fat man beyond
for this evening i'm kevin smith i am
mark bernard
tune in next time same fat time same
fat channel podcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith guard that [ __ ]
or what kind of forever
you